it's interesting I had such a huge
memory of this movie the memory was
entirely wrong hey you know I watched it
again this week and I had remembered it
very differently from how it is I
remembered it with such tremendous
exuberance but I forgot a lot of the
really all of the darkness or most of
the darkness that's in it and I was
trying to think about why that is and
one of course is the poster which is
extremely exuberant but I think more
than that the way you landed as a whole
different kind of actress was really
revolutionary I was at the very
beginning of my career and I thought
this is someone who's doing something
very different I mean there's a whole
group of people so I'm curious to hear
what you saw in the character what you
were drawn to why it was something you
wanted to do when I read it it just felt
like that's me that's me I guess most
people who love this film is because
they see themselves I think most people
feel inferior when they walk into a room
and this is a girl who didn't know
herself at all finding some kind of
formation through this wonderful
friendship and escaping a life that has
taught her nothing but to hide herself
and I just found it incredibly moving
and you know right because people do
remember it as this hilarious comedy it
is the darkest saddest comedy ever Matt
brace yourselves people you don't
remember it the way you think yeah I
hadn't seen it for many years until oh I
think in March I watched it again and it
was not shocking I'm only I knew what it
was and I'd also recently seen as a
musical of it now which is been tearing
Australia which is wonderful by the way
I heard that was bit trepidatious but
it's very very good and it just floored
me I had to I'm very glad we're talking
now because that particular screening
that I had to talk afterwards it was
also a full moon so I think this is
great planning so do you feel
differently about it now then
did then when you look at it now do you
see it yes I hear it different but even
now I think projects that I work on I
can't really see them I can feel them
and only later do I see them I kind of
work blindly and intuitively and I don't
want to know really the you know there's
a certain amount of preparation and
detail everybody does as an actor but I
don't want to fully understand things
because then I think it somehow comes
out and a pure away totally understand